la sphère loupe slicks on en parle avec
thomas carbonnier avocats ont droit des
affaires et fiscalité bonjour thomas
carbonnier merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france la première
requête avait été retoquée qu'est ce qui
a poussé cette fois la cod h à revenir
sur la sphère luc slicks
bonjour tout d'abord
effectivement vous l'avez bien souligné
cdh avait examiné ce dossier en une
première fois en chambre sur la base de
plusieurs critères c'est à dire est ce
que finalement la l'ingérence était
disproportionnée dans son droit à
l'expression est ce que les informations
divulguées
has avait un intérêt le majeur au public
est ce que étaient authentiques et ska
et est disponible en par d'autres moyens
est ce que il y avait une vraie bonne
foi de la part des salariés et ces
experts avant et donc
la série des age avait effectivement
rejeté la demande d'annulation peine
deux fois qui semble quand même un peu
contradictoire dans cette décision c'est
qu'elle dit finalement les informations
divulguées n'avais pas un très grand
intérêt pour le public or pourtant on a
vu en france le magazine cash
investigations
qui n'a pas hésité en fait à tous et
l'anc est un peu plus loin pour faire de
nouvelles révélations sur base justement
ses deux clientes et zulte et donc
effectivement ça m'interpelle c'est plus
des questions se dit est-ce qu'il ya une
contradiction qui ne peut être ignoré il
remettre en cause
finalement les motifs même jugement de
la
bécasse est ce que vaille je crois
comprendre essayer de faire ça
cette explication c'est peut-être une
des bases qui aura peut-être pencher la
grande chambre faire une nouvelle
décision je ne sais pas c'est difficile
d'aimer en tous les cas
cette première décision quand lisent cet
arrêt et quand on lit la note séparée de
juge ou le comprendre que ça faisait pas
l'unanimité cette décision sans la
juridiction donc effectivement
il y aura peut-être une surprise
les principales banques européennes
affichent un milliard d'euros soit 14%
de leurs bénéfices totaux dans les
territoires à fiscalité favorable comme
malte ou le luxembourg selon une étude
publiée hier par l'observatoire européen
de la fiscalité qu'est ce que ces
audiences à la cod h avec cette affaire
des ligues slicks qu'est ce que ça peut
changer concrètement sur l'évasion
fiscale
je crains que ce soit un peu comme les
panama paper c'est comme un cerveau
scandale qui s'offre régulièrement
la difficulté c'est la concurrence
fiscale entre différents états
c'est aussi l'intérêt du projet qui
n'aboutissent pas qu'ils sont réflexion
plus longtemps on pense notamment à
en europe un projet qui s'appelle axis
c'est bas ciel commune consolidée là
haut sur les sociétés l'idée que
tellement une multinationale
pellet sur les mêmes bases d'imposition
avec un taux unique à travers toute
l'europe pour éviter justement cette
évasion fiscale bon mais ce genre de
projet a du mal à aboutir
mais c'est dimanche à chaque fois on
découvre un nouveau scandale revient un
peu sur le tapis ce genre de projet on
l'a vu récemment au g20 avec un accord
de principe sur l'idée d'un taux unique
d'imposition bon la vraie question
derrière c'est quand même ce genre de
projet à vous tirer comment se répartit
l'impôt travers tous les états mans
c'est une vraie question c'est pas
acquis mais encore une fois ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que l'on
parle à chaque fois deux schémas fiscaux
qui sont légaux et on n'est pas dedans
de la fraude et c'est bien là on se
souvient que ce scandale en 2013 avait
éclaboussé l'ex président de la
commission européenne jean claude
juncker luxembourgeois est ce que cette
affaire peut faire jurisprudence au nom
de la lutte anti-corruption est ce que
ça peu
évitez est ce que ça peut dissuader
certaines personnes de pratiquer
l'évasion fiscale
je n'en suis pas certain que ce soit
suffisant pour être dissuasive on a vu
que price waterhouse coopers
avait effectivement passé une mauvaise
année
au plan financier suite à ces
révélations
toutefois on a aussi vu que les
suivantes il avait fait un chiffre
d'affaires record donc finalement oui
c'est vrai que la boue sur le moment
mais ça n'a pas l'air durable merci
thomas carbonnier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat en droit des affaires et en
fiscalité associé au sein du cabinet
métis